es el primer estudio importante en el
mundo sobre Omicron y los resultados
están a la vista la nueva variante puede
causar síntomas más leves pero continua
siendo muy contagiosa una investigación
realizada por una aseguradora de salud
sudafricana descubrió que la vacuna de
Fighter solo era un 33% eficaz para
prevenir el contagio en comparación con
el 80% antes del está sin embargo una
doble dosis de la vacuna redujo la
gravedad en un 70% en comparación con el
93% de la variante Delta varios
científicos sudafricanos respaldaron los
datos
65.000 nuevos contagios y levanto el
promedio de la semana a su nivel más
alto y más de un año Reino Unido con
tocase 80.000 contagios en las últimas
24 horas
en el
hospital